So what you're seeing here
are pearl ponds in rural Zhejiang.
And on the day that I visited,
the owner of these ponds was surprised
that anyone outside of her town,
let alone the pearl farming business,
would want to know more about these ponds.
70 percent of the world's pearls
are cultured and produced here.
And so each of these mussels,
they contain 40 to 50 pearls.
And the higher end ones are taken out,
sold as jewelry,
and the lower end pearls
are actually extracted,
put into smaller oysters, vacuum sealed,
preserved in formaldehyde
and shipped off all the way
to places like rural Indiana
for online pearl parties
where thousands of people sit
watching these oysters
being cracked open in real time.
Online pearl parties are truly
an internet-enabled phenomena,
growing out of platforms
like Facebook and Instagram.
Because on the internet,
no one can tell
just how bad these oysters smell.
(Laughter)
When we think of tech,
we often think of cities.
Places like San Francisco or Shenzhen,
where tech is built
and visibly part of everyday life.
Rarely do we think of the countryside,
and when we do,
it's as a place that's lacking tech,
that's lacking digital media literacy,
and we see the rural as backward.
Yet the pearl-producing towns of Zhejiang
and places in rural Indiana,
where online pearl parties flourish,
they don't just exist as an afterthought,
waiting to become cities one day.
As online pearl parties show,
rural China and rural America
are connected in unexpected ways.
And these connections need to be more
than ones of economic growth.
There's numerous stories like this.
Whether it's rural families manufacturing
for online lifestyle brands in the US
or influencers in rural China
cashing in by making livestream videos
of themselves pulling noodles,
eating chili peppers, picking tea
and, my favorite, hunting bamboo rats.
There's whole pockets of e-commerce,
whether on Amazon or Taobao,
that are sourced
from rural manufacturers in China,
made by families.
So this one family workshop
that I visited was fairly typical,
with a husband and wife
making Halloween costumes for export,
while the 90-year-old matriarch looked on,
sifting through
plastic packaging for shipping.
And across the US and China,
I've seen similar dynamics:
rural areas becoming home to data centers,
e-commerce warehouses, rare earth mines.
And ...
also top-down
entrepreneurship initiatives,
like this free range chicken
farmer that I met,
who is using chicken
biometrics tracking and blockchain
to improve supply chain transparency.
At a larger scale,
rural areas are connected
through global market forces.
Whether it's soybeans grown in Brazil,
shipped all the way
to industrial hog farms in southern China
or America's biggest
pork player, Smithfield,
being acquired by a Chinese pork company.
And even the process of hog farming itself
is becoming high tech.
NetEase, one of the world's
largest online gaming companies,
now has its own hog farms,
and Alibaba, the internet giant,
is now partnering with farms
to use AI and computer vision
in order to create a highly optimized pig.
Because the idea being,
AI and computer vision will help scale up
pork production to an unprecedented level,
meeting the demands
of a rising middle class.
So what happens when tech
and the countryside intersect?
Well, in my travels,
I’ve talked to owners of large farms
who see their work as one of inputs,
outputs, land value and land ownership.
I've also talked to small farmers
who frame their work
as one of ecology and stewardship.
That their land is a place of relations.
It's exactly this ecological framing
that reminds us that to see
and understand the countryside
is a crucial part of moving towards
a more livable future for everyone.
Because the tech that we imagine
as urbanites to be solutions,
things like online
coding classes for farmers
or, you know, factory work in cities,
all of these are still framed
as one-way relationships,
with tech supposedly
benefiting rural areas.
But when we think of something
like AI farming pigs
at an unprecedented scale
or small farmers turning
their land into pearl ponds,
it's not because
tech has found a solution.
These small farmers
turn their land into pearl ponds
because they can't compete
at a global scale against industrial farms
who are using automation,
chemicals and pesticides.
So tracing these moments in rural tech
reveals how so much
of the technology we do build
centers our consumption
and our entertainment in cities.
Besides,
some of the most thoughtful,
careful innovation
is not happening in a place
like Silicon Valley or San Francisco,
but in places outside of them.
Like Yangguang, a rice farming village
four hours outside of Guangzhou.
For years, the local agricultural bureau
had worked with farmers
to implement chemical fertilizers,
chemical pesticides,
industrial farm machinery.
And so they did this, and they noticed
a decline in their soil quality
under these modern protocols.
So the villagers
took things into their own hands.
So they do rice farming,
and rice farming is mountain terraced.
So it’s a form of natural irrigation,
with water flowing from top to bottom.
The village changed
their governance structure
so that stewardship of the rice paddies
would change every few years
via a lottery system,
which also meant you wouldn't
have contiguous paddies.
So if you sprayed pesticides
or dammed off water at the top,
you might be affecting yours
or your neighbor's paddy lower down.
They also started practicing
organic farming
and building their own farm machinery
with the help of local blacksmiths.
They also started selling
their rice online.
And while tech helped this village
steward their land,
it was really people, not tech,
at the helm of decision-making.
And so it's exactly this approach,
without boundaries,
without ambitions to scale,
that reminds us
of the humility and innovation,
its ability to change
political and social structures.
We have to see the tech that we build
as affecting a set of relations,
ecologies and environments.
Because innovation in this village
is literally an ecosystem,
one that doesn’t scale
across thousands of users
but across the spectrum of time,
regenerating the soil and community ties
from one planting season to the next.
And for that, you don't need
a legion of engineers,
millions of users or VC funding.
Thank you.
(Applause)